hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology
uh I see there are a bunch of um
questions here
let me see
Eng
asks do you believe we had an
exploration age sometimes the hype feels
exponential but maybe it's just linear
what are your thoughts
you know it's a funny thing people have
often commented on the fact that sort of
Discovery in the world seems to be
speeding up
and uh uh kind of you know it seems like
there's just more more being learned and
and more and more papers and more and
more patents all this kind of thing one
set of people says that says it's all
exponential and it's heading for sort of
the singularity of infinite kind of uh
speed of of acquiring knowledge and
another set of people say oh you know
I'm a venture capitalist and I've heard
a million pictures and they're now all
the same
and you know or or
um I think there's one quote uh you know
I was we were expecting flying cars but
all we got was you know 140 character uh
tweets or something
how can both of these be right
I think it's really very simple the the
point is that there are sort of domains
which we already know are a thing
and there are emerging areas that are
not already a thing so for example you
can have fields of science or something
where it's a well-established field it's
physics for example it's uh
um you know it's I don't know it's it's
biology chemistry whatever else
and those fields they build with a lot
of institutional structure they can uh
you know their prizes in those fields
Etc et cetera et cetera it's possible
for thousands of people to pile into
those fields and do more and more and
more work publish more and more papers
you know start more and more journals in
those fields but then you have some new
area like I don't know llm science
that just came on the scene
but that doesn't have any of that
institutional structure and if you're
tracking how many papers are being
produced being published in academic
journals for example you don't detect
that because maybe the things that are
being done in that field aren't really
quite the same Academic Way maybe
they're things that are done by tech
companies or something like that and are
presented in different ways they just
don't show up as signals on the kind of
thing where everybody knew oh we're
looking for the number of academic
papers published or something like this
so I think what tends to happen is and
this is kind of the the long you know
re-running re-running story of the
development of Science and Technology
and so on is there will be some new area
that's opened up
a new paradigm a new methodology
something like this that's the place
where there's rapid growth then after a
certain period of time you know maybe a
little bit less than a generation or so
you will get to the point where that
field is institutionalized it's got a
lot of engines running but the really
Innovative stuff has probably already
happened and maybe another 100 years
before really Innovative stuff happens
in that field again or several hundred
years and so this this idea that kind of
there's a uh that so what happens is
when you say I've got a metric and it's
based on things that already exist in
the world that metric will often say on
the one hand there's more and more
activity there's more and more papers
being published and so on
um and on the other hand it will but
when you look at them that many of them
are quite incremental and not really
adding they're not really accelerating
things in a major way but the things
that are accelerating things in Major
Way aren't yet defined how to make
metrics for them and so those things
which become the future so to speak
become the really important sort of new
directions in the future tend to sort of
go under the radar of whatever metrics
you have saying is it exponential is it
not and so on so you know I think I
myself have been lucky enough to be
involved in a few things which I think
are uh you know at least the seeds of
things which will grow dramatically in
in years and centuries to come but I
think in uh uh and you know you can kind
of watch those things happening like for
example the exploration of the
computational universe of possible
programs this field that I now call
ruliology the study of simple rules and
abstractly what do they do you know
there's a certain amount of work that's
been done on that and there's certain
growth in that area there are a number
of sort of major things that emerged
from things I did and so on in the 1980s
and so on that are somewhat known by
people but this field uh somehow
there'll come a time when there are just
zillions and zillions of papers about
this field and some people will say oh
that's a sign of amazing growth and
other people will say oh no you know
it's all they're all you know
incremental and so on on so I think
that's that's the way I I am I see it
that there is at any given time in
history there are these kind of emerging
areas they are the growth hot spots but
they're not as visible as they might be
they're only visible to people who
happen to be kind of paying attention to
those things it's often not clear how
big they're going to get but those are
the places you know rapid growth happens
in these areas where they aren't that
that big by the time they're big and
really noticeable the growth is not
nearly as rapid and so I think that's
how sort of this this uh uh sort of
seemingly paradoxical situation arises
they're both is rapid growth and there
isn't rapid growth and I think that uh
if you ask the question what's the rate
of major new science ideas let's say or
technology ideas over the course of
history it'd be an interesting thing to
try and figure out
um I don't think it's super easy to
figure that out I think that whatever
thing you make you know whatever big
wall chart you make that's a history of
of this or that thing the thing it won't
take account of is the stuff that is a
new type of thing and so it doesn't you
know it's not going to appear on the
wall chart that will be a different wall
chart for the future so to speak so it's
kind of hard to to compare these things
in a clear way you know there is a
question of of as the world gets bigger
and they're just more people and more
people doing more stuff
why isn't it the case that that leads to
more rapid growth I think I've talked
about this a bunch of times before I
think the challenge is always as soon as
things get big they get slow because
they get institutionalized there's all
kinds of structure there's all kinds of
uh kind of built-in conservatism of yes
the the 50 000 people who do this field
all believe this and so when somebody
comes along and says well actually there
might be something else that's true all
those 50 000 people are going to say no
no we don't believe that it's going to
be much more difficult for that lone
voice to actually get anywhere with what
they're saying whereas if it's a a small
young field there's much more potential
for sort of major new directions to be
taken but it's not nearly as visible
when it's at that point
all right let me see another question
here from vivalla
um
okay it's about the weather when was it
learned that about the weather being
essentially mathematics and physics
which could be utilized okay this and
then asking about making weapons that
control weather and weather conditions
and so on
so
the question of of you know predicting
the weather okay so first of all
the the sort of the systematic recording
of weather is not that old and the
people who most cared about that were
navies and particularly the British Navy
and there were I think um
uh Captain later Admiral Fitzroy who was
the chap who was the the captain of the
beagle the ship that uh Charles Darwin
kind of traveled around the world on and
found his finches and Galapagos and the
Galapagos Islands and all the other cool
things his later career was all about
kind of setting up a systematic weather
reporting Network for the British Navy
and that was probably 1860s 1870s that
that was done
and so there were
kind of that idea of systematic weather
reporting that came in in the in the
latter half of the of the uh 19th
century and
then there was a long sort of tradition
the weather forecasting and uh you know
when I was a kid in England for example
England is a place where weather
forecasting is comparatively hard
because it's not it's a place where
there's enough uh sort of
um you know pieces of ocean and
topography and so on that you don't just
get a weather system that just
translates you know just blown by the
wind from one place to another without
changing it's it's more detailed and
it's more difficult to predict the
weather and um the uh but certainly you
know in the 1960s for example there
would be you know the on the television
there'd be the weather predicting people
and they were quite
it's quite kind of funny because they
were uh
uh there was a certain kind of theory
about oh there's a hot front there's a
cold front there's this there's that and
it was kind of an art of how can you see
all these things where oh yes I've seen
a hot front and a cold front come
together like that before and so I think
it's going to rain tomorrow type thing I
mean the joke was always that the
typical weather forecasting that was
done in England at least in the 1960s uh
you would do better just looking out the
window and seeing what was happening now
to predict the weather than by listening
to the weather forecasters I'm not sure
if that was really true
but um and they also they were still at
that time I don't know if it's still
true you know on the on the radio for
example they would read off these um uh
kind of boring seeming a little bit like
financial news they would kind of read
off the the wind speed at all these uh
uh weather stations around the country
and particularly ones um out in the you
know in the North Sea or whatever else
um so
that was you know there was this whole
tradition of kind of uh uh sort of
history based weather forecasting as an
art form so to speak it kind of reminds
one of sort of uh lots of investing
kinds of things and financial markets
where people say oh yes I've seen that
pattern before whenever this goes up in
the winter then it comes down in the
summer and this or that thing happens
it's kind of a a piece of experiential
kind of uh history based kind of uh um
artistic prediction so to speak
but the first time when people
um
sort of really thought seriously about
well the the the atmosphere has a bunch
of fluids and it's it's mostly you know
it's it's air and it's water vapor and
so on when that started to get thought
about was uh John Von Neiman and the
person called Charney in 1950 uh maybe
wrote a paper or something about weather
forecasting but they tried to do weather
forecasting on an early computer on the
computer at The Institute for advanced
study in Princeton they were setting up
kind of the the differential equations
to describe kind of the the motion of
the air and uh to try and do other
forecasting and at the beginning they
were like it's just physics we can
predict it
but very quickly they realized well
actually no it's much more complicated
than that it's actually quite hard to
predict and they didn't really make that
much progress in predicting it
and then
so that was sort of the the a little bit
the beginning of that story of
um uh can we just run codes to predict
the weather so to speak
and then
I think that picked up a certain amount
of steam but then there was sort of a a
bit of a a wrench thrown in that those
works by Ed Lawrence
um in 1963 1964
I don't know how influential the paper
they wrote was in the practice of
weather forecasting it had perhaps more
influence in mathematical physics in
general but what adlerance who I knew
actually
um was uh uh he was a meteorologist at
MIT Earth scientist in general I think
primarily meteorologist at MIT
and what he did was he took the
equations of fluid dynamics in the
atmosphere and he did a so-called modal
truncation so he said let's just imagine
that there's just one or two kind of big
Eddies in the atmosphere and that that's
kind of what's mostly going on let's
write down the equations for those for
the whole atmosphere where you have all
these different motions and things
happening in different places you get a
a big partial differential equation
that's telling you the time variation as
compared to the space variation and so
on what Ed Lawrence did was he kind of
truncated that so he got a system of
just pure ordinary differential
equations just these variables depend on
these variables and there's no
dependence on Space where there's sort
of an infinite number of different
places where you have to uh we have to
account for things so he ended up with a
small system of equations that later got
called the runs equations
um and what he showed is that those
equations have sensitive dependence on
initial conditions the equations in
general if you run them you will for
most initial conditions well you'll
eventually the the on on on a large
scale you evolve to an attractor that is
it's kind of like you know there are
many ways you can roll downhill but in
the end you always get to the bottom of
the hill
um they always get to this one sort of
lowest point at the bottom of the hill
that's kind of an attractor story and
similarly with Lorenz equations you
always get to this attractor it's a kind
of complicated thing that has two sort
of uh two holes in it and it it looks
kind of complicated
on a large scale you always get to the
attractor you always get to kind of
circulate around these these two holes
and make sort of figure eight type
patterns and so on that's always what
happens from from essentially any well
essentially any initial condition
however the details of where you go are
are very different even two initial
conditions that are very very nearby
they end up in different they end up at
different phases in the attractor so the
the detail position they end up at
they're always on the attractor and
there was just chasing around the
attractor
but the details of where they end up is
different
and that was a thing that um uh that
that was kind of this idea of sensitive
dependence on initial conditions that
idea had originated
well it originated actually James Clerk
Maxwell talked about that idea in the
mid-1800s
um in connection with uh things like you
have two spheres they and he was
interested in this for the kinetic
theory of gases you have two spheres
they bounce off each other if they're
exactly aligned so they're exactly on
axis the two spheres if they're elastic
they're like billiard walls or something
they hit and they bounce back exactly
the way they came but as soon as they're
at all off off axis they'll they'll hit
and they'll be moving away at a at a
certain angle if they're then reflected
from sort of the edges of the billiard
table or something they come back and
hit again they'll be every time they
they hit they'll be progressively
exponentially further off axis so even
if they were perfectly on access at the
beginning and their you know one million
billionth of a an inch of access the
next time around there'll be 10 million
billionths of an inch and then and then
you know 100 and then a thousand and so
on and after a while they'll not be
hitting uh they'll not even be hitting
at all so to speak so James Clerk
Maxwell knew that phenomenon
um in the 1800s and uh but that
phenomenon was sort of then highlighted
uh particularly by Henry pankare around
1900 in connection with Celestial
mechanics
uh where again there can be this effect
that oh if the if the planet was sort of
uh in exactly this position then it will
kind of line up correctly and it'll get
gravitationally attracted to this and it
will follow this orbit but if it's even
a tiny bit off
that that amount off will grow
exponentially and eventually the thing
will be going in completely different
direction
so pancare wrote about this then
subsequently
um a trap called Garrett bookoff at
Harvard
um studied well this this became this
kind of field of so-called this kind of
merging into this field of so-called
dynamical systems theory
um and which was kind of a study of uh
these kinds of uh typically ordinary
differential equations there were a
whole series of these kinds of things
that got studied
um the van der Pol equation was another
one which arose in the 1930s I think in
connection with studying electronic
amplifiers and people wondered you know
if you have this amplifier it's kind of
like the thing with the balls bouncing
back and forth every sort of iteration
the effect gets bigger so to speak and
what does that mean does that mean if
the if things were just a tiny bit
different at the beginning they will
diverge
um uh rapidly so to speak
well
the thing that um so so they've been
this kind of history and dynamical
systems are in the mathematics and in
fact I think um uh Ed Lawrence was uh
somehow a student of Garrett berkovs or
some such other thing
um and so he meteorologist he writes
this paper about how there is sense of
dependence on initial conditions in
something that affects the weather
and so some said people said well then
it's hopeless you can't predict the
weather they'll always be the sensory
dependence on initial conditions now
actually that became a whole kind of
tradition the whole sort of Chaos Theory
tradition it was uh it's funny how these
things work out I mean there was a
certain group of people that were very
big on this some had come out of the
sort of mathematics of dynamical systems
theory then there are a bunch of kind of
young physicists all of whom I I knew I
know
um and uh they kind of were really the
the sort of the chaos theory uh uh you
know promoters so to speak and there
were things like the work that my friend
Mitchell feigenbaum did showing that
there was a sensitive dependence on
initial conditions but in in his case in
iterated maps just uh things like X goes
to a times x times one minus sex and so
on that there was sense of dependence on
initial conditions but yet there were
Global statements you could make in his
case about the scaling of period
doubling and so so on so there was this
whole sort of tradition of oh this
sensitive dependence on initial
conditions that also sort of fed into
all sorts of things about you know how
roulette wheels work and and how how
games have chance work because you know
the the when you flip a coin the fact
that it's hard to predict which way it
will come up is because a small change
in velocity can flip you over to a small
change of initial philosophy can flip
you over from being oh it's going to
land on heads to oh it's going to land
on tails and because you when you flip
you know when you flip the coin with
your finger or whatever can't control
that velocity precisely enough that's
why I'd say reasonably good source of
Randomness so there are many of these
kinds of situations where this happened
sometime in the middle of this there was
a popular book written by Jim Glick
called chaos which kind of sort of
fueled this kind of Chaos Theory as a
thing idea it was actually very
confusing because because you know Jim
Click interviewed me for that book and
wrote a certain amount about things
about my I don't know whether he wrote
about rule 30 but he wrote about a bunch
of stuff that came from me I'm not sure
whether it was probably attributed to me
but that's a different story
um but uh uh about kind of systems where
you get for sort of purely computational
reasons you get complex Behavior but
it's a completely different phenomenon
from the sensor dependence phenomenon in
this so just to explain
when something comes out random like I
just mentioned with coin flipping the
reason coin flipping seems random is
because we don't have precise control
over the initial conditions and the
initial conditions matter so then what
people said was well the reason there's
Randomness in the world is because we
don't have perfect control over initial
conditions and they say well what you
know maybe there's Randomness because
there's an initial condition and
depending on whether the initial
condition is point
one zero zero zero zero zero two zero
zero zero zero zero or whether it's that
with a with an extra you know instead of
the two it's a uh you know point one
nine nine nine nine nine or something a
very tiny numerical change that that
that tiny numerical change could be the
thing that gets Amplified and because we
don't know
the value of that initial condition
that's sort of why things look random
it's actually something that makes very
little sense because the this question
well why is the initial condition
unknown it's something which if you
believe in continuous numbers and real
numbers and so on you say well you know
you just throw down a real number and we
don't know which real number it is and
as you excavate it further and further
you're seeing things that we don't know
but the fact that we don't know it
doesn't mean that it isn't precise to
Define so to speak and it gets very kind
of weird because you're starting to say
well actually kind of the when you have
Randomness in let's say fluid dynamics
fluid turbulence things like that you're
Excavating down to the position of an
individual atom and then you go below
that because you know after a while it
will be sensitive to even more detail
about the initial conditions so this
kind of idea that well it's random
because there's something we didn't know
about the initial conditions that's kind
of a a it's sort of random because
there's something we didn't know and
that's kind of the question is if you
have a really closed system where you
kind of know everything can you still
have Randomness and this is part of the
whole thing that I discovered in the
early 80s with things like the rule 30
cellular automaton that even when you
completely know you've completely nailed
that what are the rules for the system
what's the initial Condition it's just
one black cell we can say exactly what
it is even when you know all of those
things you can still get apparently
random Behavior same kind of thing that
happens with the digits of pi we know
exactly how to compute them yet if you
just take a slab of digits of pi they'll
seem random when you look at them so
anyway this phenomenon of kind of
Randomness for computational reasons
intrinsic Randomness generation as I've
called it closely related to
computational irreducibility is a thing
that was not understood uh and in fact I
I remember talking to adlerance and
length about it and I think he did
actually understand it in the end and uh
but in any case what adlerance did was
widely quoted as so you can't predict
the weather because there is sensory
dependence on initial conditions in
systems like the weather and and then
and this is very confusing because in
fact when you make a small perturbation
and a fluid most of the time it just
dies out that's the nature of viscosity
you know you you make you you have your
your water and you wiggle you know you
put your hand in you flap it around for
a while the water will be all sort of
flapping around but after a while the
water will calm down it'll be perfectly
flat if there are no other perturbations
as a result of viscosity as a result of
essentially the analog of friction for a
liquid
and so it actually isn't the case that
most small perturbations in the in the
in the fluid grow and eventually take
over and dominate the behavior of the
system in fact what happens is it's only
at those points that are very kind of on
a knife edge where you know just a tiny
thing pushing one way or the other will
flip it into one situation or the other
those are the only cases where there's
this kind of sense of dependence and
there are sort of mathematical setups
that you can make where uh where you've
sort of Amplified that and what
adlerance did with his modal truncation
thing was he got rid of viscosity you
have to go to sort of all the modes to
see all the viscosity so he specifically
had a case where there are a lot was a
lot more sort of knife edging that goes
on
so in any case that that led to this
belief on the part of some people like
physicists oh you can never predict the
weather for this reason but in practice
people went right along at National
Center for atmospheric research at the
European weather prediction outfit in I
think it was in Reading England at least
at some point it was
um the uh uh they um
you know getting computers
supercomputers and so on to just try and
solve those differential equations and
see what you could say about the weather
and it gradually got better and better
and it got to the point where at least
over a few day period you could make
pretty decent predictions now it was
certainly true that if you go further in
the future you are more and more
sensitive to whether you got all the
measurements right at the beginning
um not in quite the the lorentz
sensitive dependence on initial
conditions it's all going to go one way
or the other I mean you know the the
typical thing that people would say is
you know if a butterfly flapped its
wings One Way there'd be a hurricane if
it flapped its wings another way there
won't be a hurricane well yes but only
you know one in a gazillion gazillion
gazillion cases only you know most
butterflies they'll never have an effect
most butterflies will go through their
lives and all the flappings that they'll
do will not have any measurable effect
in the future of the world so to speak
it's only that one super lucky one in
the gazillion gazillion gazillion
butterflies that will flap their wing at
just the right moment to push you over
from the knife edge from have hurricane
to not have hurricane
so that sort of got got quite confusing
but it's still the case that the more
accurate measurements help in these in
these simulations now it's also pretty
difficult to do these simulations and
there are
there's a you know you the the forecasts
have gradually gotten better typically
what's done is you'll run multiple
forecasts that have certain detailed
differences and you'll kind of see where
they all line up like you'll run a dozen
forecasts and so one of them was going
to say it's going to rain like crazy and
other ones can say it's beautifully
sunny and then when you'll see people
quoting you know there's a five percent
chance of rain or something that's
that's often essentially coming from the
fact that well of these forecasts be ran
it rained in five percent of them and so
that's kind of the chance of it raining
in in the actual world
but so you know the state of the art has
gradually improved in terms of weather
prediction that's a different thing from
large-scale climate prediction which is
a whole more complicated can of worms
and you know there are a lot of things
about modeling the atmosphere like for
example the number of layers of the
atmosphere I don't remember how many it
is but I think it's less than 10 still
layers that get modeled and it's like
when there's a cloud that's a big
problem because a cloud is sort of a
feature on a fairly small scale that can
have a big effect on things and it's
hard to model that hard to model clouds
and a bunch of these kinds of settings
and clouds have complicated physics
about when they start to rain how the
raindrops get bigger all these kinds of
things that's a whole separate thing to
talk about but hard to model
but so the question that was asked here
is is as we try and learn to predict the
weather you know can we can we kind of
weaponize the weather and things like
this you know one of the things I always
find an interesting feature of the
history of science is this question
about can you predict the weather it's
an old question and back in you know
Babylonian times people were doing sort
of astrology type things and they were
predicting sort of well where's this
planet going to be next they were
predicting sort of uh who's going to win
or lose the next battle and they were
predicting the weather and the thing
sort of interesting is of those three
things predicting the planets predicting
the battles predicting the weather
we we learned we managed to develop
mathematical science that did a pretty
good job of predicting the planets
for the weather took another few
thousand years but we've gotten to the
point where we can do an okay job at
predicting that for the battles I don't
think we've got there yet and it's sort
of interesting to realize that back in
Babylonian times would have been very
hard for somebody to know which of those
was going to be easy and which of those
was going to be hard
but any case back to the weather and you
know there's always a question of okay
can we change the weather
people talk about changing the overall
climate that's a different issue that's
much longer time scales it's just like
can we make sure that it doesn't rain on
our parade so to speak today and there's
been since the 1950s I think maybe even
earlier than that there have been a
bunch of ideas about how you might do
that mostly around this concept of cloud
seeding
and the issue is we talked about you
know how clouds make rain well the
question is what starts the raindrops
getting bigger to the point where they
actually fall out of the cloud because
there's always water vapor that's what a
cloud is it's it's a thing of water
vapor but most of the time that water
vapor is being held up by updrafts of
air and so on and there's and the water
and the the the the the
um the particles are small enough that
that works but sometimes the particles
grow by by kind of
um uh the the opposite of evaporation of
condensing onto of water
condensing from Steam onto these growing
drops they grow to a certain size beyond
that size they start crashing into each
other and they then start growing by
sort of coalescing and then eventually
they get big enough that the updrafts of
air can't hold them up and they fall
down as rain
but there's sort of a question of can
you make that process happen faster and
for example when it when a drop starts
forming it's it's probably the case that
inside every drop there's a little
nucleus that started the formation it
might be a grain of pollen might be a
grain of dust maybe for some things it's
even the result of a cosmic ray going
through but there's something in there
you know if you took apart that water
drop there would be something very very
small in there that was the thing that
caused the water vapor to at a
particular place start nucleating into a
into a drop of water and so kind of the
idea was well let's just put artificial
nuclei that will nuke that will sort of
seed water drops and then get this Cloud
that is approaching our parade to um uh
to drop its water somewhere else so it
doesn't rain on our parade it rains
somewhere else
um and there are a bunch of experiments
done I think in the 1950s on that
um in the US I think in Israel there
were a bunch done
um I don't know about other places
um
I think uh uh I mean in more recent
years China's done a bunch of things on
this
um the the concept of sort of weather
modification and you know would there be
a systematic way to do it is one that
particularly in the 1950s and sort of
the Cold War period the US was like
let's try everything
um as a way to sort of get ahead and a
lot of a lot of uh uh kind of wild
scientific ideas were investigated and
one of them was cloud seeding and
weather modification there were also
ideas about sort of large-scale weather
modification I mean I know the um there
was this facility in Alaska that got
closed down I don't know 15 years ago
now called heart h a r AARP which was
high altitude atmospheric not sure what
the rest of the abbreviation stood for
but it was something which was kind of
making an artificial Aurora it was kind
of shooting
um electrical pulses into the atmosphere
and kind of seeing what happened and you
know the conspiracy theory was that it
was some kind of global weather
modification thing not really I think
um it was for studying a sort of
electrical effects in the upper
atmosphere
um but you know that was kind of in the
direction of oh is there something we
can do to just sort of switch the
weather to do to do different things
my impression is that it really has not
been clear how to do weather
modification and that while there are
some sort of claimed successes of oh
stop it raining on the Olympics in
Beijing or something or um uh whatever
else the sort of claimed successes I'm
not sure how convincing they are and
it's one of these kinds of things where
um it's you know the weather is is sort
of has a mind of its own so to speak and
and goes off and does different things
and you see an effect happen and you can
very quickly say oh my rain dance caused
it to rain because it just happened to
rain so to speak after you did your rain
dance so I I don't know I don't know how
convincing any of that is
uh
and I think the uh the general problem
of the sort of the physics of how to
control weather is complicated and I
don't think it's uh I think it's it's
clear how that can work I think there
are some some approaches that are kind
of like more local versions of
geoengineering approaches that one might
make to climate change I don't know
enough about how those would play out on
a small scale
let's see
uh
hmm
all right you guys give me a lot of uh a
lot of challenging questions here right
there's one from Chris here are you
aware of efforts past or present of
using nature to understand mathematics
instead of the other way around
well
at some level the pythagoreans who
originated a bunch of what we now have
in mathematics particularly things
related to numbers and so on
um in a sense
they were observing things like musical
harmonies of strings of different
lengths and that's what led to rational
numbers and all this kind of thing so in
a sense they were taking the natural
world and using that as a clue to
well let's look at rational numbers
let's look at these ratios of integers
they might be interesting things to look
at I mean I would say that that um
a lot of things about physics for
example have led to thinking about
mathematics
um
I would say that there's sort of a
question of
are there cases where so so I mean
whether it's the invention of calculus
or something which was done well at
least the Newton version of it was done
in support of thinking about physics and
as a way to sort of describe the
physical world
I suppose a question you could ask is
are there things where somebody said aha
now I understand the math because I saw
something worked that way in in nature
and um
you know there are things that come to
mind that aren't examples of that for
instance the phylotaxis spirals of lots
and lots of plants where you form these
Fibonacci sequences
um when you count up uh for example the
the stamens in a daisy or something like
this I think I've talked about before
what the actual sort of science behind
that is and the 137.5 degrees and so on
of angles between stalks of plants but I
have to say that wasn't how Fibonacci
sequences were discovered invented
whatever else they were actually
probably first invented by some Indian
folk who was studying uh around 2000
years ago studying kind of the patterns
of the counting the number of different
ways you could make kind of a a piece of
prosody a kind of a way of um uh kind of
ancient rap music or something of of
different kinds of rhythms for for
saying things
but I'm trying to think about cases
where
people had sort of a a problem in
mathematics
and then people said aha we can see this
thing in the natural world and it sort
of reveals the answer to what's
happening in in the mathematics I'm
trying to think about that
um
and I'm not coming up with
great examples there's certainly many
cases where
What You observe in the natural world
leads you to a particular kind of
mathematics or particular to ask certain
questions in mathematics but the
questions once asked in mathematics are
there places where you kind of go to
Nature and see what the answer is I'm
not sure I think you could ask
um
I'm thinking perhaps something I was
mentioning earlier the van der Pol
oscillator
that um
um
no I'm not coming up with anything
immediately I probably uh I'll if I stop
talking about this I'd probably think of
something but I I don't immediately
think of something there
um
let's see
uh
Salas wishing me a happy birthday thank
you very much it was that was yesterday
um
and is asking notable things to say at
my history oh my gosh
I don't know I I keep on writing things
about pieces of the history of my ideas
I wrote
a quite a big chunk about the history of
my work on the second row of
thermodynamics which kind of started
when I was 12 years old and um it was
still going 50 years later but I think I
kind of figured out what I wanted to
figure out there
um I suppose the uh
um this one of the things that is both
a a big advantage and something that
makes things difficult is that I have
pretty good archives so I have you know
I've kept material
for the last 50 years or so and uh in
and I've had it pretty decently
searchable if not decently organized I'm
hoping eventually to expose a bunch of
that material because there's a lot of
things if one's interested in the
history of Science and Technology you
know I've been lucky enough to be kind
of involved with no people who were sort
of key figures in in all of that going
back well now I don't know 45 years at
least and I'm sort of hoping to be able
to expose a bunch of that material it's
just a lot of work to do that and there
aren't really good systems we're trying
to build a world from language based
system for doing uh sort of archival
management
um and hopefully that will allow us to
expose a bunch of things it's a tricky
thing because for example I have three
million emails
and archived and some of those emails
are interesting History of Science
emails some of those emails are
complicated pieces of sort of
proprietary information being exchanged
with some technology company 25 years
ago I don't even know if the company
still exists I don't know if that
information is still you know
proprietary to that company there are
things that are about you know people
and so on where it's kind of like well
you know it's you know detailed
interactions with people about you know
let me give you a piece of advice about
this or that type of thing those are not
things which probably one feels okay
exposing
um in the near term eventually sort of
when all the people involved are dead
you might as well expose them but um uh
the um
I think um you know I just did a thing
actually I wrote a rather long piece
about a chap I knew for 40 years named
ed fredkin uh who had a very interesting
improbable kind of life
um which I kind of explored quite a bit
of um our in the last month or two
um and uh that exposed a bunch of email
that I had with fredkin that was kind of
kind of complicated I mean kind of um uh
and I don't know what point it would be
right or would have been right to have
exposed that email I think now it's uh
it's fair game and an interesting
history
um but so this question if you take
three million emails and what do you
expose when is is a difficult one I
don't really know a great answer and you
know reading through three million
emails well it takes one would take one
a very long time to do that and uh one
needs some kind of criteria uh and I
don't know quite what they should be and
that's one of the issues in these kinds
of things now the other point is you
know you've got millions of emails again
this is both the the blessing and the
curse of having a good archive is that
that I know that there's a lot of
material about something like let's say
my interactions with Ed fredkin that is
there in my archive
and I can search for it I can pull it up
but there's a lot of it and it's then
one has to kind of pass through it if
one is doing something where there's
much less information in a sense the
history is easier one's more likely to
get it wrong but the history is is sort
of easier because there's less of it but
so I have the the the sort of the
feature that I really have stored a lot
of material and so you know many things
can be pieced together but it's also not
very interesting to just look at all
those individual pieces what I think
becomes more interesting is seeing the
Arc of various kinds of intellectual
development that I've been lucky enough
to be involved in and seeing how that
plays out over decades and uh trying to
understand what one might learn from
from sort of the way that that's that
development played out I mean for me
personally a lot of studying this kind
of history is all about being in a
better position to sort of make
decisions and predict the future it's
kind of like if I can know this is is
the pattern of how kind of particular
sorts of ideas get diffused and come to
exist in the world it helps me to see
the pattern of how that's going to come
how that's going to happen in the future
where if I know this is what it looks
like when there's this kind of hype in
the technology industry it helps me to
understand you know is what's going to
happen with the llm you know hype bubble
so to speak because how is it going to
sort of evolve over time and so on and
so that for me is an important reason to
study history even my own personal
history because you know when I
recognize this is something this is the
kind of mistake I've made before so to
speak that's a very useful thing to know
well this is something where I kind of
remember things that I I kind of
remember what happened 35 years ago 40
years ago whatever on such and such a
thing but when I really look at it in
more detail it helps me to know
something about what's going to happen
now one thing that's kind of funny and
very recent times is there are a bunch
of questions that I kind of started
asking oh
beginning of the 1980s for example and
I'm finally in a position to answer
these questions and so several of the
things that I'm doing uh it kind of
feels it feels terrible because it's
kind of like I don't think I'm getting
old but it's kind of like uh uh you know
I'm sort of putting certain kind of
intellectual Affairs in order so to
speak because they're things that I kind
of started wondering about the beginning
of the 1980s and it's like now I can
actually answer that so I'm gonna go do
it and I have several pieces that I've
been writing recently that are of
exactly that kind for example this one
I'm working on right now that probably
will get called something out of the
physics of expression evaluation that
has to do with the question of when you
have a system like wolfen language where
you type in some expression and it gets
evaluated and turned into some big
arithmetic thing or some big thing with
a bunch of functions that that compute
things and then the end the answer is 42
or whatever what does the process of
evaluation what is going on in that
process of evaluation
particularly when the process of
evaluation might not terminate and I
thought about this a bunch when I was
building SMP the kind of Forerunner to
mathematical emotion language that I
built starting in 1979 I thought about
this a bunch at that time I was really
quite obsessed with this question of
kind of how do you deal with these
layers of recursion how do you control
that how do you build this kind of
evaluation control system and so on and
now I finally understand this I think as
a result of looking at things in the
physics project and understanding about
kind of time-like evaluation chains
space-like evaluation processes Branch
like evaluation processes it's very
beautiful and very very aligned with
physics and it kind of helps when even
in understanding the physics just to see
this example an expression evaluation
but the thing that's a bit funny for me
is that I really did work pretty hard on
this around 1980 and tried to figure it
out and I couldn't figure it out and in
fact I put into SMP these mechanisms for
controlling recursion recording
controlling um the evaluation process
which I really didn't understand that
well at that time I put them in because
they're a piece of you know you can you
can Implement them but what do they
really mean I really didn't understand
them nor did anybody else over the years
I've got every so often I come back and
say can I understand these things now
finally I think I can and they were sort
of maybe not quite aligned in the right
direction but sort of interesting in in
what they tried to do but now I can
finally do this the thing that is kind
of the Lost law for me I suppose is that
right when I was doing that work back in
1980 I was also working on Quantum field
Theory and in particular on gauge
theories and in particular on all these
questions about sort of gauge invariants
and and under what circumstances it's
kind of like relativistic invariance
under what circumstances can you kind of
uh how do you assign simultaneity to
different events how do you say which
event is simultaneous with which event
that's kind of a choice of what's called
gauge
um and so I was pretty interested in
those kinds of things back then was
studying kind of that and Concepts on
field Theory and if you'd asked me back
then is this thing you're studying about
evaluation does it have anything to do
with what you're studying in Quantum
field Theory I would instantly have said
of course not it has absolutely nothing
to do with those two things are
completely unrelated well now it turns
out they are basically the same question
and this is sort of a a deep connection
between physics and computation that
manifests itself in a thing like that
let's see
uh
gosh the question from the uh Lala
what is the history of naming
mathematical terms how has this branched
off into other areas of naming
so
you know mathematics one of the things
about mathematics is it's pretty global
human languages there are lots of them
five thousand whatever it is ten
thousand if we're lucky someone go
they're going extinct at a certain rate
but there are many different human
languages they're even quite a lot of
languages that have been used for for
sort of Higher Learning over the course
of time and so there are things that get
names in different in different
languages and so on mathematics
has the sort of time for progress in
mathematics is slow compared to the time
it takes for knowledge to kind of
diffuse around the world and so there is
just one mathematics
at least there has been for a long time
probably for a couple of thousand years
and so the notation and so on is pretty
uniform it's not like okay there are
things uh you know there are few
countries or things like the number
system can be different in different
countries and there are a few kind of uh
sort of little extra twiddles that exist
in some places but pretty much by the
time you're even at arithmetic it's
pretty global and so a lot of things
that got named in mathematics uh at
least the the at the level of the
symbolism and so on it became pretty
Global it took a while sometimes for
example uh people had different
approaches to different kinds of
mathematical notation for instance the
greater than sign
in in the 1600s that was still sort of
getting worked out
leidenet scott-free leidenets was was a
big person pushing for kind of
standardization in mathematical notation
you know he was
uh in part a sort of Diplomat kind of
Diplomat he was kind of a the geek end
of diplomacy I would say he was the guy
who's kind of the back office guy who
would try to find a complicated
historical story that explained why it
was okay for person a to marry person b
or for some country to do this or that
thing he was kind of the the staff
support for diplomacy so to speak more
than the front line Diplomat but he
lived at a time when Latin was kind of
going out of fashion as the sort of
global language of learning and but he
was really Keen to kind of have a a
global language that he thought would
sort of bring people together and be a
kind of common way to talk about things
and so that was one of the reasons he
pushed quite hard for mathematical
notation and saw this opportunity for
sort of a global mathematical notation
but he invented various ideas for
example for greater than signs and less
than signs and equal signs he had this
idea it's like weighing things on a
scale if you're you know if one side is
heavier that side of the scale goes down
the other side's heavier it goes up or
if it's balanced it's kind of you know
in the middle so he had a notation for
sort of almost hieroglyphic in some
sense no Kate notation for uh kind of
greater than less than equal which were
kind of a scale tipped one side or the
other kind of an amusing idea didn't
catch on
he had other uh he had a bunch of other
notational ideas but he had many
annotational ideas that did work for
example he had the notational idea of an
integral sign you know an extended s and
one confined in his in his notes the
very place where he first wrote that
down
now he also had the idea of you know d d
y by DX for derivatives and he worried
at the very beginning he said people are
going to cancel the D's they're going to
think it's like multiplication they're
going to cancel the D's that sort of
calculus error 101 type thing that's
happened for the last 300 years as a
result of that sort of rather bad
notational choice he also there's a fun
correspondence that he had with a chap
called William outrad who's the person
who invented the multiplication sign in
which leibniz says this is a really bad
idea because your multiplication sign
looks like an X and people are going to
confuse you know is it two times three
or two x three type thing and but
nevertheless that notation kind of got
burnt in
when it comes to naming things
you know I think what tends to happen is
somebody comes up with a name and often
it makes it and sometimes it doesn't and
it's kind of a natural selection of
names I know in my own life I've come up
with some names that have made it well
and some names that I thought were
pretty good at the time that didn't make
it
um one of the ones that I thought was
pretty good at the time was the
homoplectic and autoplectic for systems
actually a little bit like what we were
talking about earlier homoplectic
systems are systems where the complexity
you see in the system comes from
something that you inject into the
system from the outside it's kind of a
same complexity type system uh something
like sense of dependence on initial
conditions where you are injecting those
initial conditions and that's where the
complexity comes from autoplectic the
idea was the system itself intrinsically
as a self thing you know it's Auto in
Greek is sort of the self prefix
um that that uh is is where the
complexity comes from but those names I
invented those in the in the mid 1980s
they didn't catch on
the uh and uh you know it's people try
and make names in in some Fields that's
pretty standardized naming and often
those names are come from Latin and
Greek Roots there's a nice book I think
I have about the origin of scientific
terms which kind of goes through you
know if you want you know assists a
trans uh a um uh whatever it is a a
different kinds of uh
um you know that there are there are
many Greek prefixes for example you know
an anti and a hyper a sub flat and a a
super right hey whatever there are all
these things that have sort of that that
often become part of mathematical naming
that um uh that come into a um
that get that used in an in medicine for
example you know there are many of these
names that come from well from uh
Hippocrates from Galen from you know
Greek Latin roots you know the ventral
side of the whatever I don't I don't
know all these terms
um you know uh for me as a kind of
amateur sort of reader of biomedical
literature and and uh you know person
who interacts with those kinds of things
it's always fun that the fact that I
know
sort of new no decently well Latin and
ancient Greek is is really useful
because I can sort of when somebody says
you know erythema or something it's like
okay that that means something about you
know redness and so on because I kind of
know that the Greek roots and that's
that's very useful in a lot of these
terms particularly in sort of biomedical
areas come from that in something like
mathematics there have been periods of
time when people have really pushed for
these kind of latinized roots that
happen in the bobaki group in France in
the um
1930s 40s and so on where that was a lot
of sort of formalization of mathematics
was pushing for those kinds of things
um I think when it comes to uh
for example things named after people
there's a certain uh certain amount of
yes it got the right person and a
certain amount of no it absolutely
didn't get the right person that was
named after the wrong person and there's
been a certain tenancy in modern times
to try and sort of right the wrongs
and they're things which used to be
called you know uh I don't know the
Friedman universe and then it became the
Freedman Robertson Walker uh Universe
the Friedman Robertson morko lametra
universe and I think it's sort of
gradually adding names on or the um uh
and sometimes you know often I think the
detailed history of these things gets
quite complicated and maybe there should
be even more names added on and that's
been sort of a recent Trend in these
kinds of things
but uh
um
I think people have tried to name things
I don't know like a recent name that
I came up with was the the name rouliad
and I like that name it seems to have
caught on quite well
and um
uh a friend of mine said to me after
seeing that name which I thought was
pretty good thank goodness you didn't
make it annoyed
uh I noted that many things in modern
mathematics it's kind of oyed means sort
of like uh and uh it's like a a um uh uh
you know you you tack oid onto something
as a kind of well it's sort of like this
but it's not quite that
um it is I think an interesting
you know place there are places in
modern mathematics that um oh I like
category Theory uh where there are all
kinds of names like an you know the Endo
Funk tour and things like this where
again knowing a bit of Greek you can
kind of translate a bunch of these
things
um and uh there's a certain tendency to
use those things but what sort of
interesting is that things like endo
uh you know hetero uh Tran whatever all
these different terms that are prefixes
that have been used enough times in for
enough purposes
in language in general that when we see
them somewhere we can associate when
something you know hyper whatever it is
um uh you know meta all these all these
prefixes they originally came from Greek
for example but they are fairly familiar
and I think that I have certainly tried
for many purposes to mine kind of uh
ancient Greek for Concepts like for
example the
um
uh
the concept of kind of knowledge
which is sort of around the logos
Etc et cetera et cetera term or the
concept of rules around the r costs kind
of term the problem is that things that
became with log they're an awful lot of
things from logic to Logistics to
um uh all sorts of things it's a
well-minded you know you don't get to
you kind of have a choice you can pick
up a Greek word that is kind of not very
familiar to people and then you can kind
of attach it and say oh look there's
this cute Greek origin but nobody knows
that you know the Greek term and um uh
the or you can pick something where
there are enough sort of English
derivatives of that term that it has
some immediate Cognitive Connection
and that but that has the problem that's
in some areas it's very infested with
Concepts that are already there you know
an example of one that wasn't and I
don't really know
uh the cybernetics which comes from
gubernator
um which is a Latin word maybe there's a
Greek one as well which means a
steersman somebody who kind of steers
the ship
um and sort of cybernetics is the study
originally of of control in machines and
and animals and so this idea I don't
know maybe it was not what we know maybe
it was somebody else uh who came up with
this term cybernetics and of course
there's a there's a there's a certain
development because in in the Original
Latin it will be gu but that was sort of
morphed into cyb and uh that term I
don't know the extent to which that term
was sort of a known term and the extent
to which it was sort of plucked out of
obscure Latin and placed in this place
um and having and then had to fight for
itself so to speak just like a brand
where you know if you call your company
you know
um
you know floxacon or something nobody
knows what that means it doesn't have a
maybe I don't know I just made that word
up but but um uh you know maybe it was
called fluxacon but would immediately
think it was some thing about change or
magnetic fields or something like that
um but you know sometimes you have a a
strong word that has sort of never been
heard before and that has to fight for
itself and when it manages if it manages
to make it it becomes something where it
it kind of is a is a strong thing or
sometimes it's something which is very
much derived from something one already
knows uh but but I think in um uh you
know maybe there are issues with naming
because there was a time when
you know most people who were in the
kind of uh intellectual sphere new Latin
for example and so you could expect that
a name that was sort of Latin derived
would be immediately sort of
recognizable to people in the same way
that an english-derived name is
recognizable to people today
so I I think uh
and I've ended up despite having tried
pretty hard to have latinized names for
things like mathematical is obviously
latinized name and I've had plenty of
others
um some things like rouliad is very sort
of I don't know Anglo-Saxon Modern
English derived rather than having sort
of classical Roots I don't know the the
uh
the precise right way to think about
sort of the theory of doing those kinds
of things often
you know there are
weird Origins
for
names I mean I don't know even even a
term like revolution of uh uh in science
or other things I I think that came from
sort of the copernican experience where
he had a book called day revolution of
us surveys well I forget the whole title
but it's about
you know the the the earth going around
the Sun and so on it's revolution in a
very a very direct sense but yet kind of
the the sort of the baggage that came
with that led that word to be used for
many other purposes and I think the same
thing has happened in in some other
places I'm trying to think of examples
in uh in mathematics and in science I
mean I would say that
you know there are words which are
pretty weird I mean like determinant
for a matrix you know you compute the
determinant
I
think that would originate in the late
1800s and probably at the time it had
originated that was yes it was the I
never thought of this before I'm sure it
was the determinant that determines
whether an equation will have Solutions
of this kind of that kind but then it
just gets called the determinant and
that sort of floats off as a name
independent name of its of its of its
own
I think the uh
uh there are weird ones like the
absolute value of something
I don't know I suppose that one that one
maybe is sort of understandable
um the uh uh the norm of something I
don't know that um there are things that
sort of have uh maybe that comes from
Norm probably comes from normalizing
things and then it got shortened to that
um and I suppose there are yeah there
are different origins of that kind
um
yeah it's a complicated world of uh of
where these names come from I know you
know I've obviously been deeply involved
in coming up with names for things in in
a very kind of forced situation of
naming the functions in modern language
of which there are now nearly 7 000 and
each of those names it's an attempt to
kind of sort of crush a little tiny
piece of poetry into that name of what
can you crush what kinds of ideas can
you crush into you know a name like Nest
list you're kind of trying to crush the
concept of what's going on into
something which is recognizable from
from English words and that's kind of
been an extreme example of that one of
the things one learns from that is the
number of weird words that are de novo
you know never seen that word before
that one gets away with using is quite
small people can learn just a few but
really not very many this was one of the
big mistakes made for example in APL
early and quite Visionary programming
language made by Ken Iverson in the
early 1960s that was kind of a he
thought of it as kind of a lang a
notation for for computation as
mathematical notation as a notation for
mathematics I would kind of say that
that's a little bit what we've now
achieved we'll go from language but in a
very different way because what Ken
Iverson the mistake he made I talked to
him at length about this
um in in in past years
um is that he invented all these symbols
he needed a special keyboard to type APL
and so on of course that wouldn't be an
issue today
um now that sort of all keyboards are
kind of soft in some sense
um or many keyboards can be made sort of
soft but uh you know the problem was the
amount that people could learn of these
sort of funny symbols of triangles with
lines through them and so on people just
didn't have a very big buffer or
patience for learning all those special
symbols and so it really didn't work if
there had been just one special funky
symbol yes you can learn it but many you
cannot you know it reminds me of another
thing which is the use of things like
Greek letters and so on to denote
various kinds of Concepts and quantities
in mathematics and elsewhere and it's
sort of fun we did a survey once of sort
of how often a different Greek letters
used how many Greek letters are used for
for many things I've always in in my
sort of Life and Science occasionally I
have to make up a notation for an exotic
thing and I I have often used the
capital PSI which is three parallel
horizontal lines
um the middle line usually a bit shorter
than the other two and I've always used
that for kind of these very exotic
things you know it's used it has various
uses like the grand canonical Ensemble
I've used it for um a kind of complexity
measure for finite automata and um it's
it's the thing you you kind of it's it's
it's the thing you roll out that has a
certain exoticness to it and there are
other kinds of things where oh yes a
parameter that's sort of a a an
eigenvalue of some kind it gets the name
Lambda usually and there's a certain
whole ethos that's developed around all
these different Greek letters you know
something which is vaguely uh you know
something small it might be a delta or
an Epsilon there's nothing about Delta
or Epsilon that makes it you know in the
abstract it's like d and e what's what's
small about DNA but Delta and Epsilon
developed this kind of uh uh sort of
Association in mathematics to small
things like for instance I don't know
capital Sigma is the whole summation
well okay that makes some sense because
it's a an S for some uh something like a
um a Tau is sort of a variant of time
and things like this then there are
Greek letters that don't make it very
often like I was the capital Epsilon
which is a kind of a a y-shaped letter I
was uh looking at a friend of mine's
book on mathematical economics and I was
uh impressed that on page one it had a
capital Epsilon
um I'm not sure what that really says
about the level of obscurity or not of
the mathematical economics
um but the capital Epsilon is an
endangered you know it's it's a I'm not
endangered it's a it's a very minority
kind of uh Greek character so to speak
uh rarely used uh or something like Iota
which has become confusing because it's
really like an eye without a DOT on it
I've I've sometimes found there are
Greek letters sometimes when I want to
go really exotic and it works better in
modern times than in the past I'll use
some of the Antiquated Greek letters
that went out of out of circulation
before the kind of golden age of of
ancient Greek so for example if you are
doing um something like you have pqr
English letters and you want
corresponding Greek letters well it's Pi
for p Row for R what is it for Q
well there's a Greek letter called
copper k-o-p-p-a which is like a circle
with a line actually looks surprisingly
like a queue now that I think about it
um that is uh
that is sort of the analog of a queue in
some sense I mean we don't know how
these things were pronounced but it
seems to be somewhat plausible that
that's the case or for example a DI
gamma that's a that's a kind of a w like
sign sound that's this sort of uh uh
Peak thing with with it's kind of like
an effort and backwards
um so to speak but uh you know those are
the things that but people don't usually
use the Dai Gamma or the copper it's
very exotic that you'll see those in um
uh uh in mathematical notation actually
there's another one with worth
mentioning which is always very
confusing it's like you may know you
know a lowercase Omega is kind of like a
little W like thing there's a thing that
kind of looks a bit like a lowercase
Omega but it kind of closes at the top
and it's used in astronomy and it's used
for the periapsis I think
um of an orbit
um and I had not known for years what
the heck that thing actually was
and I I now discover that as a curly pie
it's kind of a script like pie symbol
um but that's an example something that
used in astronomy and hasn't really been
used elsewhere it's kind of a fun thing
if one has to make up notation for
something else but it's a fun thing to
use there are also other letters that
sometimes get used uh for example Uh
Russian characters Cyrillic characters
um there is uh oh gosh there's one
the shuffarevic group I think Tate
schaferovic I'm forgetting am I
remembering the right person I'm not
sure but anyway there's a there's a um
you know that the Russian character
which is kind of like the
like a squared off W with a tail on it
um uh I think
um
is uh uh I think there's this one place
where people tend to use that in in that
particular area of mathematics you know
there are there are notations that have
caught on haven't caught on for example
in Alan turing's time when he wrote his
original paper on touring machines in
1936 he uh needed to use all sorts of
notation but he needed to use notation
for computation which was a new thing at
the time and for describing his turing
machine so he used what he called German
letters he had um he had Greek letters
and he had German letters uh which were
in fact Gothic uh letters and I suppose
maybe the term German letters went out
of popularity when the second world war
started I'm not sure
um but uh or maybe that was just an Alan
Turing special I don't know but that was
another thing where you know people use
Gothic letters for certain particular
things and and at the very beginning
Turing used them to represent
computational kinds of things that did
not catch on otherwise we would be
seeing you know every paper on
theoretical computer science will be
full of Gothic letters but didn't catch
on
um
the okay I see a comment here
that um
uh from evangelos
or the Greek sounding name the major
reason Greek has overused they say in
science is the fact that ancient Greek
vocabulary has literally a word for
everything
I would dispute that
you know it's sort of interesting you go
and look at a Greek dictionary and you
say well is there a word for computer
well obviously not
well not so obviously not because there
was the anti-cathera device that existed
and probably there was a word for that
but um uh you know there's no
instruction manual what came with the
anti-cathera device so it doesn't say
this is a uh you know a
um I don't know what the word would be
but um uh I don't know it'd be actually
nice if I could come up with a word for
computer
um the uh I mean certainly compitare
computo computare is a Latin word for to
reckon
these weird things that happen and one
of the ones that's a sort of a favorite
of mine of naming is calculus
what on Earth is calculus well calculus
is a thing not only in mathematics but
also in dentistry because it's this kind
of uh you know it's this hard plaque and
so on that you kind of get to get to
scrape off and it's but how on Earth did
those two names end up being the same
well the reason is because
these calculi were little stones that
people would use for Reckoning and so
when it came to name kind of this method
for Reckoning that Newton and leibniz
and so on had back in the 1600s it's
well let's use this thing that comes
from these little stones and so on but
the last laugh there is that calculus of
the kind that you know Newton leibniz
type calculus is all about continuous
quantities not discrete kinds of things
and yet now for example as we work on
the physics project and lots of other
things and we work on computation in
general it's all about discrete things
so it's actually the original calculate
the original little hard stones that you
would use for Reckoning that's what we
want to be talking about but the term
calculus was used was taken by this
thing it's all about continuous
mathematics so it's kind of an ironic
thing but you know I I think it is sort
of interesting that that the names there
really weren't as many things in the
world well I don't know this is this is
one of these things that you can kind of
dispute because you know I say there
weren't as many things in the world back
in ancient Greek times as there are
today but you know I'm sure in ancient
Greek times there were all kinds of
different words for the the sort of the
hood ornament on a ship or something and
all those terms kind of disappeared or
maybe there only exist in some very
specialized area today and so I I don't
know whether in fact the number of terms
I think the number of terms that were
used in sort of ancient Greek vocabulary
was significantly smaller than the 50
000 or so that are used in Modern
English for instance that's an
interesting question an easy question to
answer uh I I think it was much smaller
certainly when I was learning something
like ancient Greek you know you could
learn a vocabulary that wasn't huge and
yet you could you know pick out the
words for pretty much you know your
average you know at least Herodotus
level you know ancient Greek author
um and I think uh you know when it got
more creative like the Shakespeare in
English and they were perhaps making up
their own words it becomes more
challenging but but my impression is
that the the collection of words used
was was somewhat smaller I think um uh
the thing that
that
um I've sort of wondered I was
considering at one time when we made
image identifiers uh that can say you
know this is what five thousand
different pictureable nouns in English I
can recognize a cat a dog a teacup a
chair whatever else uh I had kind of
wondered what would be involved if you
trained an image identifier on only
words that appear in an ancient Greek
dictionary
so you get to you know for example that
doesn't include
something like a car
um and then what you do is you train it
on that you give it images of all those
things including all the different wine
flasks and all this kind of stuff and
then you show it something from the
modern world what does it say it is
um and I think that would be um uh you
know that would be sort of a fun thing
to do and it kind of speaks to the
difference in in kind of language from
ancient Greek times to today I mean
there's of course famous examples of
changes in language and and what one can
describe famous example I I've never
really dug into this one myself but
um the uh
um
uh the the color words like you know
it's I think it's claimed that in in
ancient Greek the the blue and green
aren't really distinguished in the color
words yet for example there's a famous
line from the beginning of the
the first main book of The Odyssey I
think which talks about how uh kind of
you know Rosy finger Dawn you know uh
found its way across the plains of Troy
so to speak
and that word
for you know Rosie fingered who knows
how that's you know that the translation
of that word is difficult because we
don't know kind of the mapping of what
color they thought that was versus what
we would now describe it and that's sort
of a place where it's hard to make the
alignment you know it's always
interesting that as you start thinking
about translating ancient languages and
so on this question of how do you align
what was going on then with what exists
today I know for example a chap who um
whose work I've studied quite a bit
named Darcy Thompson who mostly was
famous for his book on growth and form
that was about the kind of shapes of
biological organisms and so on but he
was kind of a classical scholar and he
wrote one book called uh Greek fishes
and another one called Greek birds and
what he was trying to do was he was
trying to match up the species that were
mentioned in something like the Odyssey
let's say with a modern species you know
was that a whale or was it a shark you
know what was this word in ancient Greek
and how did it map onto modern times and
you know who knows maybe there were
species that were still extant in those
days that have gone extinct today that
of for which there's a word you know a
kind of bird or something a Dodo or a
Dodo plus plus or whatever that um
existed at that time doesn't exist today
and it's hard to translate
um
let's see
uh
I think I'm going to have to wrap up
soon here but um
um
uh
the um
you know this question
I I mean I have to say as we're talking
about languages and words and so on
there is always this question what comes
first the word or the concept kind of
thing and that's something I've thought
about quite a bit and I think about a
lot in terms of of kind of how do we
um as we sort of expand our domain in
science and so on to what extent is that
enabled by the invention of words for
things in a sense that's what makes me
feel important as a language designer
that I'm kind of making up words for
things that then become Concepts that
people can think in terms of that helps
kind of lead the possibility of thought
out in different directions but there's
sort of this complicated Loop between
things which become common in the world
for which people make up names and can
remember what those names are and things
where one makes up names for things and
that leads one to go in that direction
typically the making up of a name for a
thing will greatly enhance the the
extent to which that thing gets talked
about because if you don't have a name
for it it's really pretty hard to talk
about it and I think uh this question of
whether there were times in history
where the lack of a name for want of a
name so to speak a concept was lost
um and I bet there have been I mean
there are also places where kind of the
notation for things has made a
surprising difference like for example
I'm pretty sure that the fact that
algebra didn't get invented until the
1400s is is in no small part a
consequence of the fact that in in
Antiquity the and in in for example
Roman times numbers had letters
associated with them and so
distinguishing a letter that stands for
a number is an obscure thing when we're
doing Roman numerals as soon as you have
Hindu Arabic numerals where the the
symbols for numbers are different from
the letters it becomes much easier to
imagine well we can have a letter that
stands for a number you know a confusing
thing about that is in Euclid uh
surviving manuscripts of Euclid
um not manuscripts not original ones but
surprise I mean surviving
things from Antiquity uh that involve
figures geometric figures
do have labels for those geometric
figures they label an angle with an
alpha or something like this or perhaps
a Theta I mean again you know how Theta
became the name for an angle I have no
idea you know maybe Euclid uh off and
you know back in Alexandria in uh you
know what is it second century BC or
something uh was just kind of hanging
out one day he's like I got to pick a
name for this let me pick a Theta
um and you know that's how these things
start and then we're 2000 years later
and it's like us the angle is called
Theta let's pick Theta as the name for
an angle you know one example of this is
Lambda functions and and Lambda calculus
and Lambda expressions and so on uh it's
a name invented by Alonso Church
um and people are still Lonzo Church why
did you call it Lambda and he says
they're well it's completely arbitrary
and you know it could have perfectly
well been called a sigma function or
something instead of the Lambda function
um but it's sort of fun to see how the
the term Lambda you know has has uh
um has found its way into all sorts of
places even though it's really quite
meaningless it's not like church said oh
I called it Lambda because it stood for
l dot dot dot
um it was really just an arbitrary
choice
um
but I think uh
yeah I think this this
question it's always interesting also
when I have written kind of when I used
to write sort of papers that use
mathematical notation a lot I've I've
for the last
um 30 years I've kind of tried to use
computational notation much more than
mathematical notation because I think
it's clearer and you can also run it on
a computer and it allows you to talk
about a much broader range of things but
back when I used to primarily use
mathematical notation
um it's it's always an art form to
figure out how do you name things like
uh you know how do you name objects that
you're talking about to sort of not be
obscure you know you can easily if if
you make up a bunch of things and you
say I'm going to call things a b c
Def
it's incredibly easy to get a
mathematical description that is just
unreadable because it's just like it's
an F it's an a it's a B I don't know
what those mean but yet if you called
one of those things Sigma and you call
one of them Kappa and you called one of
them you know capital Q each of those
things has a certain I wouldn't say
emotional but a certain conceptual
baggage that comes with it from all its
uses in different areas of mathematics
you know another thing that's quite
interesting is is the use of
multi-letter things so for example most
mathematical functions you know a Bessel
function is a j sub something or other a
an elliptic function you know a k an e a
pi whatever those are those are a Theta
for for um uh other kinds of electric
functions but then I remember when I was
well a kid actually the first time I saw
a mathematical function that wasn't a
single letter function was the function
Earth erf which is the error function
the integral of a of a gaussian
distribution it's kind of a term that
came in from statistics I think but for
me it was very wonderfully exotic to
have a mathematical function that was in
mathematical notation it didn't have a
single letter name and it sort of and
then there was started to be more like
the LI for logarithmic integral and so
on
um and uh it's kind of interesting again
there's sort of an ethos associated with
these different different names of for
example in in engineering it's quite
common to have you know I don't know
Reynolds number re things like this
um it's uh it also shows up in physics
but it came from more from the
engineering side
um and you know in these different
fields there's a different sort of ethos
of how you name things
and uh that that's it's always and you
have to when you're when you're building
out some new area you have to kind of be
mindful of this you know you either have
to invent your own conventions but you
have to kind of decide what are you
buying into and and you can make things
go from you know from very clear and
easy to understand to being completely
obscure by getting that stuff wrong
all right I see a lot of other
interesting questions and comments here
um and uh
I'm uh looking forward to talking about
them um
um
oh I see just one more I have to I have
to dive into now and then I really need
to go from uh uh Kelly Opie asking which
are better autobiographies or
biographies which gives a better
historical record of a person
um
you know that's interesting I I have
encountered that many times because I
have studied people where there are
autobiographies there are biographies
I think they
show different things I mean
the and it depends a lot on the
personality of the person
I mean the
somehow
I've seen even for myself
I remember a certain Narrative of how
certain things happened
and it's roughly right
but the big picture
often is not part of that narrative
so for example
uh in my own life
if I look at oh I don't know because one
I figured out years ago
and say how did I come to start thinking
about simple programs like cellular
automata and essentially building
science up from programs one looks at
rather than being a reductionist and
going from the phenomena of the world
down to this kind of description of the
world in terms of primitive elements how
did I end up doing this kind of build
stuff up rather than reduce stuff down
okay well I never really you know I just
like well I did it you know that's what
I did back in you know 1981 or so that
was a just a thing I started working on
and then I realized at some point wait a
minute there's more historical Arc to
this than that what was I doing around
1981 well I was building a a computer
system I was building a computer
language
and okay that's interesting then I
realize look the reason I was thinking
about building things up from Primitives
is because that's what you do when you
build a computer language before that
I've been doing physics where you're
mostly doing the reductionist thing of
going down from the thing that you from
the from the world and trying to grind
down and figure out what its elements
are but in building a computer language
you're going up from the elements and
seeing what it's consequent what their
consequences are at least that's a large
part of what you're doing so I kind of
realized from outside my personal
experience I kind of realized that you
know the picture of what was going on
was I thought of doing that because I
had had this experience in building a
computer language I realized only very
recently that um uh back a few years
after that when I was studying these
simple programs and finding out how
complicated their behavior was a number
of very good mathematicians started
working on the kinds of things I was
looking at and after a couple years they
got very frustrated they just sort of
went away they said the methods we have
for mathematics they just don't help we
can't say anything about these systems
but what I realized is what I managed to
do which again I didn't feel like
anything at the time was I realized the
very fact that it is difficult to say
something is the most interesting fact
it's not what the mathematicians were
looking for which is we want to say
something using our mathematical methods
what I realized was that it's kind of
the inability to do that that leads to
phenomena like computational
irreducibility and and so on now that's
something it took me several decades to
realize after it actually happened sort
of a good historian would see those
pieces and realize that's what actually
happened but from inside you don't get
to see that
you know I think another thing I
realized very recently is ridiculously
recently is I've worked on a bunch of
different things and uh one of the
things that's true about most Fields is
that there's a certain sort of Guild
that builds up within that field there
are people who learn the field and then
they have students and then they have
grand students and so on and there's a
certain sort of human connection Human
Social connection between the people who
do that field well I've worked on a
bunch of things where for whatever
reason I've ended up not being involved
with the field but making use of sort of
ideas from that field sometimes making
sort of contributions to the
fundamentals of the field but I've come
from outside the field and I was
realizing recently that's totally weird
it doesn't usually happen that way I
hadn't really internalized that it's
something I happen to have done and done
repeatedly but it isn't very common I
didn't realize that wasn't very common
you know I probably I could go back and
look at why did why do I end up doing
that and other people don't do it so
much and it you know might have to do
with sort of being entrepreneurially
oriented in some way I don't know I you
know I have to think about it but my
point is there are these things that you
can realize about the sort of the Arc of
history that you even though you lived
it you don't know it and if you're a
good historian or biographer you can't
see that Arc even from sort of you know
better from the outside sometimes than
from the end inside maybe I'm not sure
um I mean I I think for example people
have asked me uh another one of these
questions about some you know how can
you know they're things that I've
figured out scientifically that seem
completely at odds with my personal way
in which I conduct my life so to speak
like for example I'm very you know I
like people I interact with people
Etc et cetera et cetera right talk to
people on live streams I do all kinds of
people oriented things yet some part of
my science is a is a sort of
deconstruction of everything a very
non-seemingly non-human let's grind
everything down to its fundamental
elements that don't have anything like
people in them but yet I realized that
and by the way one of the challenges in
doing science is to do science
independent of what your Prejudice is
about what has to be true are and
mistakes that I've made in the past
slowed me down by decades have been
things where I'm like I think I know how
this works because I have this kind of
General view about how the world must
work but then the actual evidence shows
me something different and I kind of
ignore the evidence until you know
that's a big part of being able to do
these things and discover what you
didn't expect is to notice that evidence
you didn't expect but so I think uh you
know and and I have to say in
biographies autobiographies there are I
would say the number one mistake in
terms of intellectual biographies and
autobiographies is the failure to
realize that there is an explanation for
things that is that people will write a
biography and they'll say magically on
this day somebody had a brilliant idea
and they solved this
it never happens that way as you trace
back there is a thread that goes back a
decade or more and it's like they did
this they did this they did this and
that led to the possibility that they
were in the right place at the right
time to have this Epiphany that led to
this it's and you know in the efforts
that I've done in in sort of biography
and so on and even autobiography I have
been sort of very insistent on trying to
find these threads and I think often
people don't do that and so they end up
writing things that sort of don't make
sense and where they end up with
with uh well with things which don't
really they don't really give the most
interesting picture because they haven't
really put together kind of the The Arc
of the narrative so to speak so I you
know when people do that sometimes
people from the inside
autobiographically are more able to do
that than biographers can do it I think
the you know the the a good biographer
who's done a bunch of work in biography
should be able to do a better job than
the typical autobiography so long as the
material is actually accessible but
there's some some material where the
only way you know what happened is
because you were there and you remember
it and there just isn't any external
material uh of course that has the the
risk that you remember it but you
remember it wrong and you know I I find
for myself I have a pretty decent memory
uh I think and um
uh you know these live streams are a
great test of memory but uh
um the uh you know in in um
uh the I always find that you know I
have a pretty good memory but there's a
little bit more detail
um uh in um you know in what actually
happened then the the gloss that I
remember on it
um anyway so I I have to say I find both
biographies and autobiographies
interesting to read I am more often
frustrated by biographies than I am by
autobiographies I mean autobiographies
they say something even if the whole
thing is a total gloss even if I know
it's a whitewash it's interesting that
it is a whitewash whereas if it's a
biography that it's a whitewash it's
like who cares or if it's a biography
that's an attack biography I was very
frustrated recently I was looking at I'm
trying to understand the the biography
of a founder of immunology and there's a
kind of attack biography of him and I
don't know why it's an attack biography
I don't really understand but it's hard
to actually get through that to what
actually happened and I but I think if
that was written by the person
themselves it would tell me you know and
it's a biography with a certain slant
that gives me an autobiography with a
certain slant it gives me information
whereas a biography with a certain slant
gives me very little information the
slant is irrelevant so to speak
anyway a few thoughts but um thank you
for asking lots of interesting questions
and um look forward to doing this
another time
bye for now